الرجل الذي يأكل دجاجة يوميًا لمدة 40
يومًا يستحق
فرصة أن تبدو سئمًا أيضًا إذا كنت
تطعم نفسك
دجاجًا مشويًا كاملًا كل يوم قام ألكسندر تامينسكي المقيم في فيلادلفيا
بتوثيق قدميه
وصولًا إلى العظام التي
ربما فقدها فيلادلفيا فيليز  بطولة العالم التي
أعادها رجل الدجاج حقًا إلى المنزل ،
نمت شهرته على الإنترنت وبحلول الوقت الذي
ظهرت فيه منشورات تعلن أنه سيأكل
دجاجته الأربعين على رصيف مهجور ، فلا
عجب أن ظهر حشد من
الدجاج قال لصحيفة نيويورك تايمز إنه
فقد 16 رطلاً  في تلك الأيام الأربعين ،
سئم من الدجاج لدرجة أنه بدأ في مضغه
إلى قطع ثم غسله
بشكل أساسي شربت الدجاج ،
ووصف الرجل الذي صور هذا الفيديو
تقنية رجل الدجاج في
تدليك اللحم بأصابعه إذا كنت ترغب
في تسهيل تناوله عند
العظام  تم انتقاؤهم نظيفين
[تصفيق]
رفعهم رجل الدجاج منتصرًا ، وكان
يقذفهم أحيانًا إلى الحشد
حتى أنه غنى على طول شوارع سبرينغستين
بفيلادلفيا.  فقط
أنت وأنا صديقي
بينما كان يزيل اللقمة الأخيرة
ثم رفع اللوحة الفارغة ،
قد يقول المعجبون الأجانب رجل الدجاج
للرئيس ، رجل الدجاج نفسه أخبر الأوقات
التي يسعدني أن الأمر انتهى على جسدي جاهز
للإصلاح للبعض  فيلادلفيا كان الأمر
بالغ الأهمية والملحمة عندما صعد روكي على
درجات متحف فيلادلفيا
للفنون ، فالصخرة هي كيف فشل الجهاز الهضمي لرجل الدجاج
[موسيقى]
Genie Mouse CNN New York